the indian capital has imposed a
week-long lockdown
after a deadly surge in covet cases
fatalities hit a daily record in new
delhi on tuesday bringing the nationwide
total to more than 180 thousand
hospitals across the nation are severely
overcrowded meaning new coveted patients
are simply being turned away
there are widespread reports of
ambulances loaded with bodies dropping
them off at crematoriums and it's fed
the official death toll
could mask the true scale of the crisis
public health expert
aman gupta told us the situation is dire
the indian situation right now is very
very grim with
curve doesn't really you know continue
to go
up it will be very difficult for them to
sort of
look at you know really exports i think
the current
uh situation for indian government is
will be to really ensure that they have
enough supply for the the domestic
population
but to your question about exports i
think that is something which will
now have to be reassessed the bigger
issue is
the the lack of diagnosis because there
are cases where people are not able to
you know detect um the kovic 19 through
the regular testing and you have to go
for uh
for a different mechanism and also i
think the other challenge which is
emerging
is that it's hitting the uh the
population of a younger
age which was not the case in the in the
wave one
india registered 273 000 covered
infections on monday alone
with numbers remaining close to record
highs
but while the caseload source the
vaccine rollout is failing to keep up
only a small fraction of the population
has been inoculated that's despite india
being the world's
largest vaccine producer manufacturing
many of the shots used in the west
india has also signed up to produce 200
million doses for up to 92 countries as
part of the who's kovacs program
although those supplies are now on hold
the government
has moved to restrict vaccine exports to
make up for the domestic shortfall
a delhi medical association doctor told
us india can no longer afford to send
its shots abroad
with a large size country like us our
coverage is
less than 10 percent and
the we were we did not had
so many of vaccine too less to have the
impact on the herd immunity and on the
coverage of the vaccination
it will be difficult for india to keep
up
to keep pace with their international
obligation in the present situation but
what the country is facing it will be
problem for the countries
who have depending on india every
country will have to depend on their own
resources